new champions of Dancing with the Stars
are we're keeping our eyes on you james
van der beek you stole the show on
Dawson's Creek and now you're making
headlines with your professional dance
partner Emma Slater there's no way of
knowing if you'll wind up on top but
we're super excited to find out we just
hope you found a way to cope with the
show's tightly wound rulebook being
chosen to become a contestant on Dancing
with the Stars may seem like a dream
come true but celebrities have found it
challenging to abide by every single one
of the show's rules keep watching to
find out which rule has disqualified
dancers in the past spray-tan Sundays
there's a reason why the cast of Dancing
with the Stars has an effervescent glow
and no it's not performance jitters it's
heaps and heaps of spray-tan producers
want their contestants to look their
best on stage and according to them
spray tans are a must no ifs ands or
buts wink contestants sign their
contracts they accept to get
spray-tanned
every single Sunday no exceptions pack
your bags the couple that gets kicked
off the show on elimination night has to
catch the first flight to New York City
this way they can conduct an exit
interview on Good Morning America the
very next morning but since packing
takes a lot of time every contestant is
required to pack up all of their
belongings on elimination day just in
case they don't make it to the next
round
makeup hair action celebrities tend to
have their go-to makeup artist and
hairstylist but when they agree to
compete on Dancing with the Stars they
sign away their right to bring in their
own pampering crew teams of in-house
professionals are assigned to each
contestant and they use plenty of
strange techniques to keep the stars
makeup and hair in place worst of all
contestants can't refuse the treatment
even if that means getting your hair
glued down with eyelash glue remember
your lines producers and writers do a
great job of coming up with
potential storylines for every seasons
couples and while the show might not
come off as scripted it certainly is
producers use rumors to their advantage
using them to shoot the show storylines
and contestants are made to go along
with whatever is written in the script
so if two contestants are rumoured to
have romantic chemistry they might be
compelled to act this out on stage for
views be there or be jobless when you're
competing on Dancing with the Stars you
have more than a few obligations to
respect on top of rehearsing for
countless hours contestants are expected
to conduct press interviews at a
moment's notice if they fail to respect
their social obligations they can get
kicked off the show like that so it's no
wonder that producers hire backup
celebrities in case their contestants
disrespect their contracts clear your
schedule celebrities who get approached
to become contestants on Dancing with
the Stars tend to have a limited dancing
background this can make learning
exceptional routines all the more
challenging to become a participant on
the show celebrities have to clear their
schedules and devote their time to
rehearsals on average dancers rehearse
anywhere from 30 to 50 hours a week but
some have spent hundreds of hours
perfecting their footwork don't complain
about your outfit if a participant has
an issue with how their outfit looks
they might as well keep it to themselves
because they're literally forced to wear
whatever outfit gets assigned to them no
matter how flashy or revealing it is be
careful what you say when you agreed to
join the cast you basically sign your
right to privacy away contestants have
to wear their mics at all times
this way every single little thing they
say gets caught on camera celebrities
are made to turn on their microphones
while rehearsing and performing the only
time they can turn them off is when they
go to the washroom
respect the beauty team's wishes
producers of the show want to ensure
that every single contestant looks the
best they possibly can so they hire a
beauty team to give them tips on how to
look fresh and silky smooth so if a
beautician tells the celebrity to
exfoliate before bed refusing to do so
would be a contract breach newbies only
if there's one thing that can get a
celebrity kicked out of the cast before
they step foot in rehearsals it's a
dancing background anyone who has been
trained in ballroom dancing is
immediately put on the know dance list
have you subscribed to the things yet if
you haven't hit that subscribe button
and ring the bell to get notified
whenever we post a brand new video if
you're watching on your mobile click on
YouTube settings and turn on
notifications this way you can be the
first to comment on our videos that's a
wrap on the 10 strict rules Dancing with
the Stars contestants are made to follow
who's your favorite dancing duo of all
time sound off in the comments thanks
for watching don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up see you